all right in a minute 20 seconds with
our friend shawn merriman before the
radio audience odorants good to see you
sir good see you too how much ink do you
have what do you have uh seven seventeen
seventeen seventeen is counting yeah
yeah stop counting now what's the first
my lights out one actually when I was in
high school my sophomore year that's
where you got it that's where I got it
and you got that because you uh knocked
out four people in one game myself yeah
four people in one game yeah three in
the first half
okay and so who is the one who used the
phrase lights out uh me you know it was
well what happened was right after the
game I would say about twenty students
come running up to me after the game and
they said man you knock these guys
lights out and I just played it cool and
I said yeah call me lights out and their
name it just is stuck with me all the
way through high school college and in a
probe huh yeah and so then you got the
attack I got the tattoo my sophomore
year I big my mom actually taking me and
I said man we got it you know people
call the lights out you guys I got to
get a tattoo represent and so you're
sack dance in the NFL it looked like
you're just doing that but it was you
literally turning your erinc on and on
at all but my rook freshman year at the
University of Maryland almost got me
pulled out the game by rough region on
ESPN for for doing a dance so I didn't
listen too much obviously Shah Maran
here on the show back in a moment
alright welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show follow me on Twitter at Sean with
Annie Merriman three-time NFL Pro Bowler
eight seasons in the league with the
Chargers and the bills who play each
other week number two with an
interesting possibility with what could
go down in the parking lot as we saw on
Twitter with our next guest from the
world bare-knuckle fighting federation
as well Shawne Merriman good to see you
bro zi2 rich I appreciate you dude the
pod with me and my wife the other day
and we and we didn't talk football we
didn't we hardly talk football at all
right but she also knew you back in the
day when she covered you at Maryland
yeah I'm from back there and you just
told an interesting story about how
Ralph's region almost kicked you out of
a game or sat you down or benched you
because you were doing too much
her lights out dance see how you did my
freshman year at the University of
Maryland because I got the light switch
in the right form I made a big hit
against Georgia Tech and he ganking out
the game and told me if I ever did to
dance again I'll never play here again I
mean obviously I didn't listen so that
uh that stuck around so I guess if you
keep sacking the quarterback you can do
your dance as much as possible hey you
know he ripped me down the middle I mean
he really tore me up but when I got to
the sidelines the my teammates and I
rested rest of the coaches they loved it
so uh at that point I knew I did
something right right know what are your
thoughts on what's going on at Maryland
right now you know it's it's it's tough
because you you have a coach or coach is
trying to come in and change the
environment trying to trying to change
the culture but first things first you
have to protect the players and a young
man lost his life that could have been
avoided so you never want to push guys
or players to the point where exhaustion
- when he having some kind of health
problem because from what I understood
he was you know he told the coaches or
told staff and people around that hey
I'm having a problem and it would this
whole thing could have been avoided so
it's it's it's sad I sad all the way
around because University of Maryland I
really feel like was gonna come up I had
a great job of recruiting some really
good things going on at the school but
you know we got a young man who loses
his life it now the focus is on is on
that well did Dirk he never reach out to
you because I know coaches reach out to
alums and you are one of significance
from Maryland did he ever reach out to
you yeah we we stayed in contact here
and there but I talked to the really a
lot of people in the staff and some of
the people who was still dare to
University of Maryland when I was there
and I my annual coat drive that there
every year going up my my 16th annual
coming up this this fall your coat drive
wouldn't win a coach job in the
University of Maryland but it's just so
much going on there and it's you know
it's one of these things where you don't
want to you know come down on the
coaches because I didn't know everything
that happened just yet I think they were
still going through what the situation
was when I found out that this thing
could have been avoided
um it was it was still with terrible so
did you hear of hey coaches a little out
of control or what's going on here it
was always a little bit of that of those
rumblings and I saw a big article I
think it was written in the Baltimore
Sun in Washington Post about some of the
guys and coaches just going overboard
and not respecting the players and you
know you want to come in like I said you
want to change the culture you want to
change the you know set the tone and
lock Rome especially when you have these
new coaches coming in but there's a
point where you have to protect the
players and it you know I just I don't
think that happened Shawne Merriman here
on the Rich Eisen show and while we're
on the subject of serious matters so
many players come off the field
certainly in a position like you played
where there is always a collision on
every play and you were the one creating
the collision yeah
players step off the field and they're
concerned about what's going on inside
their skulls with their brains and you
are now entering the world bare-knuckle
fighting Federation why are you doing
that you know it's rich it's funny we we
talked about it some time ago and I've
always said that if the right
opportunity came about for a fight that
I was gonna take it and I've talked some
other leagues and I've been witness for
a long time you know being able to being
around these fighters for the last you
know 12 or 13 years my life training
with them being around them I said look
I always wanted to do this but the
opportunity never presented itself so
when they reached out I thought it
couldn't be more perfect for what I
wanted to do so I think we got a date
set November 9th and we gonna get it on
yeah no you are but you're not concerned
about your health or anything like wow
people should be more concerned about
the other person's health
okay you know for me it's about training
I love I love being around these guys
and I were totally respect the game
respect these fighters and which is why
I never got into it to try it out
because fight fighting to me it's not
something you try out you don't go and
say hey I want to go test this out and
see how this goes
no no you do what you don't do it and
you know what I made a commitment some
time ago to go and do it and you know
world bare-knuckle fighting for
Federation stepped up it was gonna
happen
yeah you're fighting late
all in Casper Wyoming yes sir the rise
of the Titans a global pay-per-view
event and you started your training here
in Los Angeles pay-per-view man I mean
that's for me to come and do what I did
on the field and I love the game of
football I don't think there's anything
I could have done better and wanted to
do as I was growing up but I always
thought the bigger opportunity was was
waiting for me for me this is it right
and your training here are you with
glaze yeah Jim we won't talk about him
too much after this I mean that's the
most I'm gonna talk about Jay yeah you
know we that's my man but yeah so I get
a chance to be around if you have some
great fighters some great trainers yeah
I'm in a gym probably about three or
four hours a day
Joe shilling I'm also going to work with
him so I get a chance just be around
some great fighter which I have been
okay for the past 12 or 13 years how's
your staredown game because you know
when you're gonna you're gonna be fit do
you know who you're fighting at or you
don't know no but yeah at this point it
doesn't matter okay so you know you just
how is that are you working on that
stand in front of somebody and listen
you could you can stare down as many
people as you want but when that bell
rings you know the staring the staring
goes away no we've had fighters on
brockman you can back me up on this
we've had fighters on and it's it's
apparently the first time you ever do
the coming together stare down right and
you're so close to another human being
how much huff it's tough to not laugh
right it's tough to not understand if
the other individual is a not showered
or B has some form of a halitosis
situation going on and that could throw
you off you are I'm just trying to walk
you through this Shawn yeah this is by
the way I'm not gonna give you tips on
how to bare-knuckle fight that um I'm a
blank slate you are gonna need a whole
lot more than bad breath to get out of
this loss okay you know situation if
they get that works they can try it so
let's put your paparazzi hat on a little
but for this National Football League
season coming up who do you think has
the best team going in this year who do
you like for this 2018 NFL's you know
this this season is wow because you can
have you know team like the Eagles that
you know
Carson Wentz back and they have a chance
to repeat I mean they're practically the
main part of their team's is back you
know you always got to throw the
Patriots up there a little bit somewhere
right because they just find a way to
win football games no matter who they
have coming in and outside the door but
also you know my former team to charges
you have to look at them because last
year and and the road that they went and
went in nine straight and starting out
on four with a brand-new coach moving
from you know they made a big move from
San Diego to LA they don't have those
distractions this year so on paper and
someone asks me the other day but on
paper there's probably the best team
they had since the mid-2000s they just
can't fall in that trap in and listening
to the outside people and really going
and just taking care of business how
much of a red ass is filip I mean give
me give me the behind the scenes here I
mean he said I'd loved interviewing him
yeah I love his energy is positive
energy it's incredible he's got all
those kids his family life but when he
puts on the helmet he seems to just turn
into a different guy you know Phillip is
the he's the biggest competitor I've
ever had a chance to play with number
one not a linebacker not a D lineman
often something Oh Phillip he cares
about winning that much and everything
he does and goes about his day is about
winning I'll never forget you know some
of the earlier seasons that we had I had
early on in the mid-2000s when we
started out on one two and on three
Phillip would get us together and get
everybody ready to run through a wall I
mean he gave those type of speeches and
when you have a quarterback that's
willing to go out and lay it out in the
line and he wants to win that bad
keep him himself he can get other guys
going to to make things happen
what would you say give me an example of
what this well first of all he never
cursed so that was it was hard it's
always hard to give the best speeches
but he did it never dropped it is more
affection it's more in fact if he
dropped an f-bomb or something I was
this close from getting him to drop an
f-bomb one time and I thought I did and
I was gonna be the first one to ever do
it and he didn't do it I knew that if I
couldn't get him to do it then it was
impossible you know I curse this huh
never cursed not one time and that's
that's what kind of weird right because
you hear people say these things about
Phillip
and obviously the the opponents in fans
or whatnot a Cutler yeah right but you
know he has a whole bunch of jerky
motion with his head he's pointing his
finger but he's saying all positive
things and it really creeps you out and
I don't know he's just you know he's
somebody that you can always count on
being there no matter what and long gap
in his physical play well he can't throw
the ball down you know 60 yards 70 yards
down the field anymore do these things
his driving and in spirit to win to
compete it's gonna take him much much
further so when we see him say Barkin at
his own sideline to keep the punt team
from coming on because it's fourth and
19 he's still fresh he's gonna make it
right
when we see him barking at Jay Cutler
across the field when we see him there's
had another somebody on another team
never once is it a curse work is what
your snot one time ever and he would
feel Philip was that NC state when I was
at the University of Maryland which he
never won against me oh yeah we I mean
he was the only quarterback actually I
didn't to the game his senior year yes I
was laying on him and as I was getting
up he was twisting my ankle what he was
twisting my ankle and he squared up with
me in the endzone and at that point in
time I knew that this was a different
different calf Rivers oh yeah he squared
up him in the end zone he was ready to
go and so by luck of the draw I get
drafted by the charges of 2005 and I'm
playing with this guy that I just
finished squaring up in within the end
zone but he's uh you know just outside
of having a great football plays it's a
great person around all around a couple
more minutes here with Shawne Merriman I
want you to tell the Ray Lewis story
because I paraphrased it you told it
again on the podcast that I do with my
wife Susie you told this story I did no
idea although it makes sense that you
played football in the Mid Atlantic and
you're from the area yeah Ray Lewis
would would reach out to you at some
point to try and counsel you or talk to
you or whatever be a mentor but you're
tight with ray correct yeah I have been
since I was you know practically a kid
16 17 years old his actually his younger
brother Keon Lattimore played running
back at the University of Maryland so
that's where I kind of
really close with Ray and whatnot but yo
ray and I we used to talk 3045 minutes
every Saturday night before a game on
Sunday and Ray Lewis would get be
getting ready for a Ravens game himself
professionally y'all you up here in law
and Southern California yeah we would
talk almost just about every night
before every game just about the game
plan and what we're gonna do and he
would always say look let me tell you
something Shea he'll come with shade let
me tell you something Shay you got to go
out and be a lion for 60 minutes i'ma
run through everything right so I'm
sitting there it got to the point where
I had to not talk to him anymore because
I couldn't sleep I would get so hyped up
from you know that's just going back and
forth what we're gonna do on Sunday that
I would have to hang up the phone to get
off the phone with them so I got the
honor and a privilege to be there doing
his Hall of Fame induction I was
actually in the hotel room when he got
them when he got when he got the
knocking I got there about a couple
hours before they tell you to be in a
room from 3:00 p.m. to 4:00 p.m. you
have to be there hour and and stay in a
room who's in the room so it's a you
know ray his mom and Keon you know his
brother hmm so we're sitting there and
I'm nervous I'm a nervous wreck you
would have thought that I was I was
someone's coming to knock for me but I'm
sitting there and I'm waiting and we
hear it we're hearing knocks and his
people coming in in and out of the room
but it was it the hall it wasn't the
hall and I got to the point where the
third knock I was like me you know y'all
got to stop you got to stop because I
got to the point where I felt honestly
like I was about to pass out because
every knock you know 315 325 345 finally
like around four or five or four ten it
came and knocked and to me that was so
special to be a part of because for one
I always looked up to Ray as older
brother as a mentor somebody who I
wanted to emulate my game like and to be
there on the biggest stage the biggest
day and in your football life was was
amazing what was the weekend like you
were a part of yes part of his group in
Canton right yeah so I was here I was
also invited out to catch and spend time
with his family his mom and friends and
you know the van or a party had a night
before at the hall yeah I know everyone
in there because
they were different of Ravens or
Maryland so that was kind of my
affiliation and it was it was just it
was special as a special weekend for me
I got the opportunity and a no honor to
Guam for LT LT action to come out
LaDainian for here for here it's done
back to back you back to back I got a
couple more left who do you have uh
Antonio Gates and then Phillip Rivers
hopefully hopefully Lorenzo Neil because
he deserves being a halt to you know
theirs would you not agree Chris there's
an argument as to where the Philip
Rivers is a Hall of Famer there's a
there is an argument I don't think there
should be one because he's never won or
a ring well Fouts is and he never won a
ring either but and philip has broken
all of them i can't compare the the the
years are just different the games
different the rules are different i mean
but i understand what you're saying guys
but yeah well this listing said and done
I mean Philip will have more than enough
numbers to get in it just matters of I
guess opinion of the board and whether
they should get it or not or whether
he's gonna be a first ballot if you know
I'm biased so I'm obviously gonna say
he's you know he should bring in you
know Antonio Gates he'll be another one
a first ballot and Lorenzo Neil you know
best let's go back to ever to me to ever
play the game
that's a tough order getting a fullback
in the Hall of Fame yeah but he he's the
last to me he's the last one of the
dying breed that should get in because
the game has changed now we're four
backs aren't part as big as part of the
game as they used to be but when it was
he was the best at it good to have you
here man I'd love to have you as much as
you want to come yeah thanks I'm you got
it
so we'll find out shortly who is writing
that was the for the world bare-knuckle
fighting Federation the meantime go to
lights-out brand calm because your your
cell and athletic and lifestyle apparel
that's right you're wearing it right now
yeah correct a little black t-shirt with
the lights out logo that's a face of
people of somebody whose eyes or ex
doubt exactly because I saw because
you've not perfect nickname for your
next endeavor of world very uncle
fighting good to see you Sean thank you
you got it phone lines are lit about the
best conference in college you want to
ask that question best conference in
college football going 2018
no I'm gonna stay away from I'm gonna
say big Tim but you know I know
everybody gonna say SEC is that what is
that where things come
least and right now SEC taking over or
no no no big ten forty two weeks I've
pounded the table for the big tent top
bottom yeah there's a lot of folks on
the phone I knew we'd smoke big owl from
Alabama out okay we'll take some phone
calls and we come back Shawne Merriman
here on the Rich Eisen show thank you
for coming by follow him Shawn with an e
Merriman here on the Rich Eisen show the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience